all right so the biggest hack maybe in
in youtube history i've ever seen happen
tuesday
basically channels little nazak's
channel eminem's channel drake's channel
taylor swift channel ariana grande
channel harry styles channel the weekend
michael jackson kanye west and like 100
or a bunch of other vivo channels were
all hacked and the same video was posted
on all i don't think that's the biggest
hack ever on youtube comedy central has
an entire channel we're talking about
hacks on youtube so this is this is the
video this is literally like the whole
[ __ ]
and this was just posted just on all
these channels all at the same time
[Music]
that's so fire
i hope the song slaps bro
i'm excited
oh from spain
really
what's going on this is making me feel
weird bro
it's funny
okay that's the whole video the only
thing that bothers me about this what i
feel i think a hypnotizer yeah they did
it to be like weird and funny and just
like that's what hackers do they just
cause mayhem this is a real marketing
opportunity you could have put any fire
video up there what would you put buddy
son a clip of my stand up probably oh
you know you would put your clip up oh
my god there's a real marker how do they
get into all of them that's what i'm
curious about does vevo have some back
channel i have a theory
miles i cannot [ __ ] wait
to [ __ ] all over whatever you said he
killed the annie milinakis one yeah he's
one of them
all right you're plus one he said i have
a theory to lower the expectations
you'll notice yeah you taught me that
last week he learned go uh i have a
theory that all of the passwords were
roughly the same and then they used a
different word at the back end of the
password so all the front ends of the
password were let's say password a set
of numbers and then the back end was
probably
something to do with the
artist yeah the artist if it was taylor
swift it's taylor swift so someone found
the first one and went there's no chance
it's the same way
and then once you have two you have 50.
interesting theory al is shaking his
head i think vivo is a manager on all of
these accounts and so once you get
vivo's password you have all there i i
that's kind of what i think
right it's like
because the managing account has access
to all the accounts below it
yeah that was very good
but see how much better it is when you
just go i have a theory yeah now we
can't [ __ ] all over you like we used to
no no i think we should
i mean
it was so complex and like miles did you
really like the mastermind thing and
then i was like hey buddy how about
they're just the manager
what's crazy is that he uploads the
youtube i know and he's a manager at all
these accounts i know i know
so did you really think for example
in order to for vevo to protect their
artists and their platforms and their
pages they would simply just use the
password
password and then the artist name that
was just an example but i was saying
there's some keyword at the front and
then the artist name at the back
and you don't think the artist would go
huh mine is blah blah blah my name i
wonder if other people's is the same
thing their name maybe it was an artist
that did it oh [ __ ]
so vivo is owned
not by youtube
a lot of animosity coming this way
owned by warner university
again watch this so someone
someone got hacked over there that's key
to all this but it didn't come through
youtube it came through vivo which is
from the record labels maybe those
artists are all friends if you could
hack any page what would you hack
hezbollah
palestine
students for justice
and he was just standing in the middle
of it and there was like one size like
pro power bro what did he facetime you
or he just sent you a video he sent a
video and it's like i don't know who to
choose
and that was like you sure you want to
come to new york
spirit airlines three stops
you'll get here don't worry